as long as I'm president of the United
States Iran will never be allowed to
have a nuclear weapon good morning I'm
pleased to inform you the American
people should be extremely grateful and
happy no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime we
suffered no casualties all of our
soldiers are safe and only minimal
damage was sustained at our military
bases our great American forces are
prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world
no American or Iraqi lives were lost
because of the precautions taken the
dispersal of forces and an early warning
system that worked very well I salute
the incredible skill and courage of
America's men and women in uniform for
far too long all the way back to 1979 to
be exact
nations have tolerated Iran's
destructive and stabilizing behavior in
the Middle East and beyond those days
are over Iran has been the leading
sponsor of terrorism and their pursuit
of nuclear weapons threatens the
civilized world we will never let that
happen last week we took decisive action
to stop a ruthless terrorists from
threatening American lives at my
direction the United States military
eliminated the world's top terrorist
Qasim soleimani
as the head of the Kurds force Salamone
was personally responsible for some of
the
worst atrocities he trained terrorists
armies including Hezbollah launching
terrorist strikes against civilian
targets he fueled bloody civil wars all
across the region he viciously wounded
and murdered thousands of US troops
including the planting of roadside bombs
that maim and dismembered their victims
Salah mani directed the recent attacks
on US personnel in Iraq that badly
wounded for servicemembers and killed
one American and he orchestrated the
violent assault on the US Embassy in
Baghdad in recent days he was planning
new attacks on American targets but we
stopped him solemn and his hands were
drenched in both American and Iranian
blood he should have been terminated
long ago by removing solemn a knee
we have sent a powerful message to
terrorists if you value your own life
you will not threaten the lives of our
people as we continue to evaluate
options in response to Iranian
aggression the United States will
immediately impose additional punishing
economic sanctions on the Iranian regime
these powerful sanctions will remain
until Iran changes its behavior in
recent months alone Iran se ships and
international waters fired an unprovoked
strike on Saudi Arabia and shot down two
US drones iran's hostilities
substantially increased after the
foolish Iran nuclear deal was signed in
2013 and they were given 150 billion
dollars not to mention 1.8 billion
dollars in cash instead of saying thank
you to the United States they chanted
death to America in fact they chanted
death to America the day the agreement
was signed then Iran went on
a terror spree funded by the money from
the deal and created hell in Yemen Syria
Lebanon Afghanistan and Iraq the
missiles fired last night at us and our
allies were paid for with the funds made
available by the last administration the
regime also greatly tightened the reins
on their own country even recently
killing 1,500 people at the many
protests that are taking place all
throughout Iran the very defective jcpoa
expires shortly anyway and gives Iran a
clear and quick path to nuclear breakout
Iran must abandon its nuclear ambitions
and end its support for terrorism the
time has come for the United Kingdom
Germany France Russia and China to
recognize this reality they must now
break away from the remnants of the Iran
deal or jcpoa and we must all work
together toward making a deal with Iran
that makes the world a safer and more
peaceful place we must also make a deal
that allows Iran to thrive and prosper
and take advantage of its enormous
untapped potential Iran can be a great
country peace and stability cannot
prevail in the Middle East as long as
Iran continues to foment violence unrest
hatred and war the civilized world must
send a clear and unified message to the
Iranian regime your campaign of terror
murder mayhem will not be tolerated any
longer it will not be allowed to go
forward today I am going to ask NATO to
become much more involved in the Middle
East process
over the last three years under my
leadership our economy is stronger than
ever before at America's achieved energy
independence these historic
accomplishment shades our strategic
priorities these are accomplishments
that nobody thought were possible and
options in the Middle East became
available we are now the number one
producer of oil and natural gas anywhere
in the world we are independent and we
do not need Middle East oil the American
military has been completely rebuilt
under my administration at a cost of 2.5
trillion dollars u.s. armed forces are
stronger than ever before our missiles
are big powerful accurate lethal and
fast under construction are many
hypersonic missiles the fact that we
have this great military and equipment
however does not mean we have to use it
we do not want to use it American
strength both military and economic is
the best deterrent three months ago
after destroying 100% of Isis and its
territorial Caliphate we killed the
savage leader of Isis al Baghdadi who
was responsible for so much death
including the mass beheadings of
Christians Muslims and all who stood in
his way he was a monster al Baghdadi was
trying again to rebuild the Isis
Caliphate and failed tens of thousands
of Isis fighters have been killed or
captured during my administration Isis
is a natural enemy of Iran the
destruction of Isis is good for Iran and
we should work together on this and
other shared priorities finally to the
people and leaders of Iran
we want you to have a future and a great
future one that you deserve one of
prosperity at home and harmony with the
nations of the world the United States
is ready to embrace peace with all who
seek it I want to thank you and God
bless america thank you very much thank
you thank you president Trump addressing
the nation after those Iranian missile
attacks on an airbase in Iraq at which
American forces were stationed and he
said that no Americans were harmed in
that attack and that damage had been
minimal Iran he says appears to be
standing down for too long he said
nations have tolerated Iran's behavior
those days are over he announced further
immediate punishing sanctions against
Iran let's go straight to our White
House correspondent Kimberly halket who
joins us now from the White House what
do you make of it Kimberly I don't think
this speech is going to satisfy ordinary
Americans who were looking for answers
on next steps we started to get an
indication before the speech was you
know delivered by the US president that
perhaps his supporters in Capitol Hill
were buying the president time they were
making statements particularly some top
Republicans that the president was
showing great restraint that he would
respond at the time of his choosing I
expected that we would even hear
something like that from the president
but we didn't and it's unusual and shows
the inconsistency of the president given
the fact that his statements leading up
to all of this was that he would respond
if Iran were to attack US interests
without hesitation not only has the
president hesitated but he's also now
essentially not delivered the answers
that people were looking for in terms of
what is your next step now of course
operationally there's never going to be
a telegraphing but again this doesn't
seem to answer some of the big questions
and again shows this inconsistency with
the US president on the one hand talking
tough saying he will respond without
now he is hesitating the other thing
that's not in there is evidence
something that members of Congress
particularly have been looking for and
the American public that is already
war-weary and looking for an end to the
conflicts looking for this president to
keep his campaign promise to end the
forever wars as he called them on the
campaign trail back in 2016 but he's
certainly not given that promise either
and then finally there's an interesting
almost campaign mode to this speech and
that is the fact that Donald Trump has
once again blamed his predecessor for
the predicament he's in that's going to
be unacceptable to so many Americans
three years into a presidency you can't
continue to blame your predecessor but
this is an obsession of this president
to blame President Barack Obama for the
jcpoa that agreement that Donald Trump's
has long criticized that of course is
pulled out of saying in that speech
there that it's now time for the other
nations that have been part of that
treaty in trying to put that agreement
rather together to withdraw from it he
pointed the finger at top allies the UK
Germany France Russia China to break
away from the deal whether or not the
nations will be listening to this
president is unclear but certainly it's
not a new argument he made and I suspect
when you pull back from this speech that
many Americans will be dissatisfied with
it
al-jazeera's White House correspondent
Kimberly Ellicott reporting live there
from Washington well harrumphing and
totting his way through that speech next
to me here in the studio which is almost
as entertaining as as listening to the
president's mispronunciations and
watching his facial gestures is our
senior political analyst Marwan Beshara
what did you make of that well it's
certainly a big whimper as it were but
still quintessentially Trump so all the
problems that we're facing now is all
Obama's fault because Obama did this and
that and the other thing blaming all on
Obama while he the president has fixed
everything fixed the economy fixed the
security the military on
so that's bitties
quintessential Trump I think the bit of
the menacing tone was not so menacing
after all because it was very general
about that we have missiles and and we
are more than ready and so on so forth
but nothing concrete nothing detailed at
all in this access civility u.s. doesn't
want to use its military might its
economic strength is its best absolutely
but that's what exactly failed over the
last three years it's the maximum
pressure strategy through sanctions
against Iran
that basically did not contain the
bellicose leadership of Iran did not
[ __ ] it and in fact Iran has been
more active not less active over the
last two years as the pressure that's
not to say that it didn't hurt the
sanctions have hurt Iran and Iran's 2020
GNP will be 10-15 percent less than it
is this year so it is hurting but it is
not diminishing Iran's capacity to
operate in the area whether it's in Iraq
Syria Yemen and so forth what is
interesting too was the very very end I
and I expected something bigger
it didn't come through maybe this is
maybe this is one speech out of many but
he did that did leave the door open
towards the end saying we do have common
interest and that is combating - Isis
and hence there is a room for
cooperation on this priority so he did
leave a bit of the door open on the
other hand in as far as strategy is
concerned it's interesting that despite
his bombast about about American power
he's saying he's asking NATO yes to come
in right that's a big deal because NATO
the NATO members in as far as whether it
is Turkey France Germany or others are
more than excited about the Iran nuclear
deal they did not want to Walker than
Iran nuclear deal and they have been
saying that all this mess basically is
because president from walked out of the
deal and yet he and Ian here is in that
speech calling on Britain Germany France
Russia and China to abandon that nuclear
deal completely it's dead he says
and that's why this is a quintessential
Trump speech basically flipping things
around that's not to say that he won't
be asking I'm not sure NATO could or its
NATO members or the big members of NATO
have any appetite to be fighting Iran or
to be confronting Iran or to be
deterring Iran or to be amassing forces
or operations or planning operations
against Iran I am Not sure I mean I
don't think France or Germany in are in
any mood let alone Turkey to be
confronting around in the battlefield
this is not Afghanistan and the United
States is the one that provoked as it
were by the by the declaration of war
killing an Iranian general okay no no
one Bashar are many things to do sorry
I'm saying I'm saying no I'm talking to
my director who's speaking to me am I am
I here normal Bashar our senior
political analyst many thanks indeed
let's go live now to Tehran and our
correspondent dosa Jabari who was also
listening in to that that speech it was
very late late at night there in Tehran
what did you make of it Dawson
well as Marwan mentioned we were
expecting a lot more it was a whole lot
to do about nothing really
we heard the US president say that they
gave Iran ian's 150 billion dollars
after the signing of the jcpoa in 2015
well the United States didn't give
anything to the Iranians this was money
that the US had held they since they
imposed sanctions on Iran since the
Revolution of 1979 so it was technically
Iranian funds that were held in the
United States and until the jcpoa was
signed was part of the agreement under
the deal for Iran to get their money
their own money back to be released into
Iranian government's hands so that was
the first point I wanted to mention the
second was that he said that instead of
saying thank you they chanted death to
America after receiving the the 150
billion dollars he talks he spent quite
a bit of time talking about the nuclear
deal clearly he wants the other
signatories that are still left in the
deal to withdraw from it but we've heard
from the French president macron who
spoke to Hassan rouhani yesterday for
over an hour on the phone that they are
still committed to this deal this is a
very important deal even though the
United States abandoned it almost two
years ago now the Iranian have said this
deal is much more than just about Iran's
nuclear program it's about stability and
security in this region that was that
one of the main attractions of this deal
to all parties involved aside from the
nuclear deal he mentioned that Iran
seems to be backing down I don't know if
the US President had heard any of the
comments that came out of Iran all
throughout the day we heard from the
supreme leader who said that this was a
the missile launched at the US base in
Iraq was a slap in the face and that if
the United States doesn't listen to this
warning there is so much more ahead so
that was the first thing and then the we
heard from Iranian president Hassan
rouhani as well as the foreign minister
and then the defense minister all of
whom have said that the assassination of
Qasem Soleimani
is a declaration of war and thus the
United States listens to Iran's demands
they withdraw their troops from the
Middle East there is so much more to
come in the days weeks and months ahead
so for the US president to say that Iran
appears to be backing down or standing
down is something that is very very
gonna be very confusing here because
that is clearly not the picture we have
in the Capitol all day today also many
thanks indeed let's go what live now to
Baghdad al Jazeera similar 14 is their
way what did you make of that Simona
well there's certainly going to be a lot
of relief here in Iraq many people here
are worried that these tit-for-tat
attacks between the u.s. and Iran on
Iraq rocky soil could further escalate
so of course this speech by President
Donald Trump basically saying that Iran
appears to be standing down and
basically asking for negotiations to go
forward to try to de-escalate these
crises have to find some common grounds
we'll certainly be welcome among Iraqis
here but also it remains to be seen
whether the relationships can be
repaired so quickly because the thing
that has happened here over the past few
days has been in many ways unprecedented
we have a prime minister that has taken
a very strong position against the
United States
he has advocated for the complete
withdrawal of foreign troops from Iraq
including US troops and the Parliament
has actually voted on that decision so
it remains to be seen whether the Iraqi
government will once again be willing to
try to restore the trust of the United
States and to basically balance out
these relationships it also remains to
be seen whether there will be additional
retaliations by for example pro-iranian
groups here in Iraq against US troops we
have had some paramilitary leaders today
say that the attack from Iran was just
the first step that they would also be
avenging the death of a bomani Armah
Hondas who was also killed in that u.s.
strike who is the second-in-command of
the Iranian back popular mobilization
forces so if we see additional attack
on basis where US personnel are
stationed by these Iranian back groups
it's entirely possible that this could
escalate again so for now there is some
relief here in Iraq but this crisis is
by no means over some other body thinks
not a zero sum wonderful team there live
in Baghdad now in terms of tangible
action here's what President Trump
actually announced as we continue to
evaluate options in response to Iranian
aggression the United States will
immediately impose additional punishing
economic sanctions on the Iranian regime
these powerful sanctions will remain
until Iran changes its behavior live now
to the Pentagon as a serious practical
heinous they're so punishing further
punishing sanctions economic sanctions
against Iran
paty nothing to do with more military
engagement in fact the president said he
wants to get NATO more involved in the
region I took that as the most
interesting line Adrienne because the
president it seemed as if there was
something that was supposed to come
after that in his speech but then he
went and continued to move on but yes he
said it is time for a NATO to get more
involved he'd in mind this is no lies
that he has spent the last three years
complaining about belittling saying that
they don't do enough and now he likes to
take credit for increased military
spending he often confuses the money
that these countries give to their own
defenses which is how NATO works with
money he believes that they're paying to
NATO but he said he wants to see NATO
get more involved and then he went on
this very long riff about how the US
doesn't need middle e middle eastern oil
anymore that it's self-sufficient he
really seems to be signaling what he's
always said on the campaign trail is
that he wants to pull US troops out of
out of foreign posts and bring them back
home he said we should spend that money
rebuilding infrastructure here in the
United States now he didn't go that far
but he put out there as far as from a
military's perspective is that NATO
needs to step up the u.s. needs to step
back so how does that all shake out well
you can bet that they're going to be
asking that question not just here at
the Pentagon but in capitals all over
the world
old paddy for the moment many thanks
indeed paddy contain their live at the
Pentagon in Washington